it's a showdown in Houston with the
leading Democratic candidates all
together on stage for the first time
former Vice President Joe Biden is the
front-runner followed by Senators Bernie
Sanders Elizabeth Warren and Kamala
Harris trailing in the polls are South
Bend Indiana mayor Pete Budaj edge
Senator Cory Booker former cabinet
secretary who Leon Castro former
congressman beta O'Rourke senator Amy
Klobuchar and businessman Andrew yang
viewers can expect spirited discussion
of democratic priorities expanding
health care reducing gun violence and
overhauling the immigration system but
polls show Democratic voters have one
overriding priority first and foremost
they want to beat Donald Trump next year
and while they may not always articulate
electability quote-unquote as a major
concern in polling the unifying theme is
fight and beat Trump the candidate who
can you know show competence in doing
that I think is likely to attract a lot
of support so far that has benefited
Biden who's seen as best able to reach
out to voters in Rust Belt states like
Michigan and Wisconsin where Trump
narrowly won in 2016 but the choice of
Texas as the venue for this debate is
also significant for decades Democrats
have dreamed of moving this state into
the Democratic column analysts believe
this could be the election in which that
happens Texas is a dynamic and changing
state we've got urban professionals
suburban professionals from around the
country moving in we've also got a large
multicultural population coming of age
and beginning to vote those the
combination of those factors is changing
the state's politics in a massive and
rapid way a lot of the president's
rhetoric against immigrants the policies
in these detention centers around the
border most of which are in Texas by the
way that combination of factors has
begun to galvanize Latinos in a way in
this state that they haven't been
previously if Texas went Democratic the
Republicans would have virtually no
chance of winning the White House just
before the debate the Democrats got some
good news
a new poll came out showing the top four
candidates Biden Sanders Warren and
Harris all running ahead of President
Trump by significant margins but it's
still more than four hundred days until
the election rob reynolds al jazeera
Houston